[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vis avec 55 % de capacité
respiratoire
je vis sur la limite tout contre la
mucoviscidose
j'ai été diagnostiquée de cette maladie
quand j'avais deux ans et puis de suite
les médecins ont dit à mes parents
vous avez quatre ans devant vous déjà
finalement que j'étais enfant j'étais
plutôt en forme
et puis on était quatre frères à la
maison elle samedi après midi on faisait
bien le bazar alors mon père nous
emmenait dans la voiture ils nous
emmenaient dans le village à côté à 3 km
et nous rentrerons courant alors il y
avait celui qui courait devant pour
éviter les embrouilles et puis celui qui
courait derrière en pleurant parce qu'il
s'était fait pousser dans les orties
voilà c'était comme ça que je faisais du
sport le sport c'est bénéfique pour ma
santé ça me permet de faire sortir ce
que j'ai dans les poumons
et puis à la tête ça fait du bien la
maladie a évolué les années ont passé et
je pourrais pas vous dire le nombre de
fois où je me suis retrouvé tout seul
dans mon lit à pleurer le nombre de fois
où je me suis retrouvé tout seul au
milieu des champs insulté le ciel à lui
dire mais mais pourquoi moi qu'est ce
que j'ai fait j'ai pas le droit aubenas
et puis petit à petit je me suis
retrouvé à besançon mais je courais j'ai
couru quinze minutes j'étais tout rouge
j'ai vomi j'ai craché du sang je me suis
dit mais c'est terminé je ne courrai
plus jamais puis avant la greffe de
poumons et à partir de ce moment là bas
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps à attendre
alors j'ai attendu après les médicaments
les antibiotiques les perfusions les
médecins les chercheurs
la greffe de poumons finalement
j'attendais quoi jeu tandis que
j'attendais de crever quoi j'attendais
de crever et
et j'ai une prise de conscience j'ai
pris conscience
j'ai pris conscience de l'urgence de la
vie de l'urgence de la vie jusqu'à mai
26 ans en fait toute cette période
correspond à une période de déni de la
maladie où je portais un masque je fais
semblant de plein de choses
j'étais normal en société l'image du
mois qu'ils étaient tous là haut alors
qu'en réalité quand j'étais sous
perfusion chez moi j'étais bien bas et
puis finalement entre ces deux
situations élastique qui a fini par
péter c'est ce qui m'arrivait j'avais
beaucoup de colère en moi j'en voulais à
dieu à mes parents à la société au monde
du travail aux filles à la terre toute
entière
je me sentais seul et a compris j'avais
peur d'être rejeté et puis cette maladie
j'en parlais pas et j'ai envie ronde et
un et au lycée personne ne savait où ici
personne ne savait bref j'étais plein de
fausses croyances est taillée limitantes
et au fond de moi pourtant je savais je
savais que c'était bien meilleur que
tout ça et puis way jésus c'est triste
cette prise de conscience pardon de
l'urgence de la vie l'urgence du temps
qui passe je veux dire si ce italie elle
n'est pas tel que tu ne souhaites
aujourd'hui cet avis ne correspond pas
c'est pas la faute des parents c'est pas
la faute de dieu c'est pas la faute du
médecin c'est la faute de personne c'est
ta faute
c'est toi qui as le pouvoir c'est toi
quand le contrôle pour changer les
choses c'est toi le patron c'est toi le
boss tu toi qui décide ce que tu peux
faire ce que tu peux pas faire c'est pas
ton médecin et c'est encore moins la
maladie moi je suis un spécialiste de la
maladie
je teste plein de choses au quotidien
tous les jours pour être mieux demain
bref pas le choix tu as choix de rester
dans ton canapé las d'attendre de
plaindre
et puis d'attendre de crever ou tel
choix de te lever te battre et d'aller
chercher le bonheur partout là où il est
donc qu'est ce tu choisis lève-toi quoi
lève toi ta joie de voir le verre à
moitié vide ou de voir le verre à moitié
plein c'est le moment c'est maintenant
que ça se passe
tel capitaine de tournage est le maître
de ton destin à l'envers
bref bref voilà cette prise de
conscience et la vie c'est comme le
poker
si tu mises pas tu sais pas donc t'as
rien à perdre
la première chose à faire c'est vrai et
authentique d'être vain avec ses peurs
ses croyances ses valeurs devrait avec
son corps et puis devrait avec les
autres et plus tu seras vrai et
authentique
puis tu vas rencontrer des gens vrais et
authentiques également des gens qui te
ressemble
et puis et puis des gens de plus en plus
extraordinaires de plus en plus positive
de plus en plus optimistes bref tu n'es
pas seul tu n'es pas seul
va voir les gens va voir les gens bref
avec tout ça en tête
eh ben j'ai claqué mon livre est jeune
et je me suis acheté un beau vélo je me
suis fait plaisir
et puis je suis allé rouler deux fois
nous trois fois par semaine 20 km 50 km
et moi ce que je préférais c'était avoir
un adversaire devant moi moi ce que je
préférais c'était d'aller rouler un
temps comme aujourd'hui c'était aller
rouler quand il y avait un avis de
tempête
quant à utiliser moins 20 ou quand il y
avait l'orage j'adore cinq ans j'adore
ça et où les ça je me retrouvais à
besançon à rouler un jour y faisait
froid il y avait du vent il y avait un
petit crachin bien dégueulasse l'arrivée
sur le côté et je me suis dit mais merde
quoi merde y'a pas de sportifs et du
sport sans bisou sur bouquet de fleurs
sans gloire sans podium et surtout sans
médaille et surtout sans idée de
progresser progresser dans le sport et
face à la maladie la meilleure façon de
combattre la maladie
c'est pas de conserver la capacité
respiratoire c'est pas de défendre la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué
donc j'ai poussé un petit peu plus fort
sur les pédales et puis malgré ça eh ben
je me sentais comme condamné à faire du
sport il fallait que ça sert à quelque
chose
il fallait que ça vaille le coup et donc
je me suis mis à écrire je suis à écrire
parce que j'avais la tête pleine de
questions planent négative plein plein
plein de colère encore et j'ai couché
tout ça dans mon journal intime j'ai
écrit quatre pages
je suis allé dans ma douche derrière
je me suis dit waouh je pense pure et
puis en parallèle je me suis trouvé des
modèles philippe croizon qui a été
amputé des quatre membres qui a traversé
la manche à la nage
maud fontenoy gérard d'aboville quand
tous les deux traversé l'atlantique à la
rame
et puis mike horn j'adore mike horn et
et là je me suis dit je me suis dit que
si pour tous ces gens là c'était
possible de réaliser leurs rêves
eh bien ça pouvait être aussi pour moi
finalement et moi mon rêve c'était de
courir un marathon
voilà
on est 7 avril 2013 vous êtes sur les
champs-elysées dans le sas de départ du
marathon de paris
il ya quarante mille personnes autour de
vous trente mille personnes sont prêts à
tout donner
aller jusqu'au bout de chemin pour aller
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout de ses 42 km
la tension est inouï vous êtes terrifiés
vous êtes terrifier les mots vous
pourrez envie d'en découdre
vous êtes un lion êtes à lyon vous êtes
un lion en cage parce que maintenant de
paris il ya tellement de sang derrière
tout ça c'est un baroud d'honneur
ses poulains le médecin lui a dit que
c'est impossible que vous allez faire
marathon de paris
c'est prouver à vos parents à votre
famille vous prouver à vous même et puis
aux enfants qui nous regardent que vous
pouvez le faire
partant de paris ça fait six mois
seulement que vous courrez cinq six sept
séances par semaine
vous êtes vous avez dormi jusqu'à 3
heures du matin seulement
cette question dumas ont fini on veut
vous gagne ou on échoué en mer c'était
comme ça donc
donc vous êtes dans le sas de départ et
ça y est c'est parti on court et le
marathon de paris le défi sportif c'est
aussi l'occasion de se reprendre
au lieu d'avoir une maladie qu'il prend
toute cette place au quotidien eh ben la
réduire à pas grand chose
et puis finalement l'écraser commune des
clubs bref au cours et puis derrière 30e
kilomètre papa [ __ ]
maman je t'aime c'était le moment c'est
le moment de faire des erreurs on arrive
dans le monde les droits du bois de
boulogne
il ya un tour montparnasse en face c'est
ce petit point blanc tout en haut de la
tour que vous êtes focus dessus petit
croisons il n'a pas abandonné au cours
40e kilomètre la rage lahrache [ __ ]
parce que c'est bon ça y est elle est le
faire il est là votre rêve
il est là il est juste là juste là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14h41 4h41 stella trois fois que ça se
faisait en france c'est impossible c'est
impossible d'en attendre paris jeudi
fait trois fois en 2014 j'ai mis quatre
heures raté une et puis en 2015
pendant trois mois j'ai compté que
jusqu'à 4 1 2 3 et 4
j'allais être quatre heures j'ai mis
quatre heures 54 secondes
le défi sportif le dépassement de soi de
manière générale c'est aussi une
aventure humaine parce que ya ma famille
il ya mes amis et puis orient ils y ont
rien que là derrière son masque et
oriane elle vit avec la demande la même
maladie que moi et ont rien n'est dit à
sa mère à la rentrée je vais m'inscrire
athlétisme pas ce que je vais faire
comme paul c'est extraordinaire et puis
ces mêmes parents comme sa mère qui
viennent me voir et qu'on a les larmes
aux yeux parce que tu peux avoir 30 ans
tu peux avoir un travail tu peux avoir
une copine tu peux courir des marathons
et malgré le diagnostic de la maladie
ben leurs enfants qui est grand comme
saïda vivre il va vivre c'est
merveilleux ce extraordinaire pour la
copine cerveau
ça c'est fait et nous pendant trois mois
en fait j'étais envahi d'un sentiment de
joie profonde
un bonheur waouh et non un sentiment
également de toute puissance
j'avais un truc qui coule dans mes
veines jusqu'au bout de mes doigts war
j'avais le power il pouvait m'arriver
n'importe quoi il pouvait me tombait de
météorite sur le coin de la gueule
j'allais m'en remettre quand même
c'était extraordinaire
derrière l'été arrive les gens partent
en vacances mais des belles photos sur
facebook mais moi je vis toujours avec
la mucoviscidose et il fallait un
nouveau défi pour continuer à faire du
sport alors je suis allé voir mon frère
jeudi 15 août 2013 et puis je dit écoute
tu fais quoi semaine prochaine ne disent
rien je dis ben on va prendre le trafic
des parents on aménagea peut on enlève
les sièges
mais maintenant la place moi je prends
mon vélo puis toi tu me suis avec le
trafic
et puis on verra bien jusqu'où on va
alors lundi matin à 10h30 on est parti
de la place saint-pierre à besançon le
lundi soir l'étape omar c'est sympa
pomarin l on n'est pas loin de bordeaux
d'ailleurs c'est pareil la copine le
margot aussi j'aime bien donc pommard le
lendemain le mardi on est à nevers le
mercredi nevers bourges vierzon
romorantin on s'est fait piquer par les
moustiques en sologne chambord lendemain
chambord cheverny chenonceau tour saumur
angers 200 km j'ai raté mon frère au
ravitaillement avec les figo lui est un
j'étais très fatigué alors j'ai fait une
petite halte dans le village du bousier
parce que tu es vraiment bouvier et puis
derrière on monte sur nantes vannes 20
noeuds samedi je me le samedi je me
rappelle de tous les villages avant
vannes textes musiques divia klaus
bernard dans le désordre mais j'avais
très mal aux fesses
c'était très très dur et un le soir on
était à lorient et le dimanche lorient
contient concarneau pont-aven quimper
audierne et vous l'aurez compris ceux
qui sont bons en géographie j'allais
vers l'ouest vers la lumière vers la
pointe du raz
j'aime beaucoup cette photo et je pense
qu'elle me caractérise aussi j'aime
beaucoup les contrastes et au premier
plan on a toute cette énergie toute
cette violence avec la côte qui est
déchirée par les vagues une inspiration
et puis à l'arrière-plan le soleil qui
vient se baigner dans l'océan tout se
calme cette sérénité cette paix et moi
j'aimerais être là bas j'aimerais
toucher l'horizon
j'aimerais m'asseoir là bas j'aimerais
embrasser le bonne voilà ça c'est mon
histoire
ça c'est mon histoire est maintenant si
vous deviez retenir deux choses la
première c'est affronter vos peurs ils
poursuivront toujours donc affronter des
monts il est temps de regarder la
maladie dans les yeux des problèmes dans
les yeux en face à face faire face
georges guynemer c'est un os de la
première guerre mondiale
j'adore l'aviation est un quand tu
confronte à tes peurs tu prends
confiance en toi tu tu apprends tout est
dit 2e la deuxième chose à faire c'est
de réaliser ses rêves rêver rêver
alors je vous ai mis demain il fera jour
es12 mettre à jour c'est peut-être pas
ambitieux mais quand vous serez au fond
du fond se dire qu'un demain sera un
autre jour
demain demain je serai mieux demain je
serai mieux demain je serai mieux demain
je serai mieux je me suis dit je me suis
dit 'ça des jours et des jours et des
jours
demain il fera jour bref rêvé rêvé
l'espoir l'espoir c'est vital et pour
finir un on est à la rochelle je
voudrais en profiter que je suis devant
vous en plus il ya le séant derrière il
ya le phare du bout du monde c'est
extraordinaire enfin bref
merci merci à la mucoviscidose de me
permettre de faire ce que je fais est le
seul que je suis dans ma tête parce que
tout ça c'est grâce à eux et pour finir
voilà moi si je le fais moi ce que je
peux faire tout le monde peut le faire
je vais pas en train de me dénigrer
c'est ce que je suis en train de dire
c'est que toi tu peux le faire
toi tu peux le faire toi aussi tu peux
le faire vous êtes tous extraordinaires
la vie c'est maintenant toucher
l'horizon
moi j'ai commencé mon intervention en
disant que j'avais 55 % de capacité
respiratoire
mardi j'étais à l'hôpital j'ai telle
mesure à 65 % de capacité respiratoire
au médecin il a cru que la machine est
aveugle
c'est vrai c'est vrai il a cru que la
machine est donc toucher l'horizon à
l'ego
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]